There are eleven major muscle groups of the body and I'm just going to go through them really quickly
I'm not going to talk too much about the names of the muscles,
but I want you to get a sense for where they're located on the body.
So:  the arm, the leg, and the core.
And I'll write that over here.  So...
The eleven groups:  there are three...
actually, four in the arm, three in the leg, and four in the core.
And just being familiar with where these muscles are
is actually really, really helpful and powerful,
because when you go to the gym or you're working out somewhere else,
it's important to stretch these muscle groups out.
It's important to also focus on each one and try to figure out which one is weak or strong
and develop whichever one is imbalanced
--that's if the left and the right side are not equal in their strength.
So, it's important to be aware of where they are located and we're going to go through that really quickly right now.
So, let's do the arm first.
You have first the forearm.  You can see that one the best from the front.
And above that you have the biceps,
that's about right there.  This is your biceps.
And behind the biceps --actually on the other side-- is the triceps.  That's right there.
And above both the biceps and the triceps is the shoulder.
And actually, I'm going to draw that right there.
You actually see it from the front and the back.  I'm just going to draw it right there, just for simplicity.
So those are the four arm muscles and now let's just jump down to the leg
and put in the quads.  This is your quadriceps.
And this is actually called the quadriceps because that's just four different muscles working together.
And below the quads, or actually on the other side of the quads, rather,
is your hamstring.  And right here is your hamstring.
And I want to get a special kind of shout-out to the hamstring because
it does a lot of work and a lot of people forget to stretch it out;
and you can often get in a lot of pain for not having a good, stretched-out hamstring.
Below it is the calf.
There's the calf...
and the calf is actually
sitting on the opposite side of the bones in the lower leg --the tibia and the fibula--
which is why it's so bony on the front part of your lower leg,
but on the back it's very meaty and "muscle-y."
So you have three leg muscles there.
Now lets put in the core muscles.
So you have, let's do the front first.
So right here is where people talk about getting a six-pack --your abs.
That's an important muscle group.  It helps you do sit-ups.
And above it is your chest, so right here is your chest.
And...there are two in the front...
and, similarly, there are two in the back.
And so the back ones --let me do in yellow--
are your trapezius.  And trapezius I think  comes down like a diamond, almost...
kind of like that.
And it helps with the neck and upper back.
And then, almost like you have wings in a way,
you have two other muscles --or actually, another muscle with two sides on it--
called latissimus dorsi.
It's actually kind of a large, spread-out muscle --and I'm not drawing all of it--
but basically it kind of spreads all the way to your back
and it is
the major muscle of your back.
So when people say, you know, "I threw out my back."
Often times, if it's the lower back, they're talking about their latissimus dorsi.
And that means that we have now our four core muscles showing up here as well.
So counting them out we've got our eleven muscle groups.
And so just to, again, go over it very quickly.
We've got one shoulder, biceps, forearm, and triceps.
In our leg we have our quad, our hamstring, and our calf.
And then in the core of our body we have our abs,
our chest, our upper back --which would be the trapezius--
and the lower back --which is the latissimus dorsi--and there are eleven groups.